tuesday against san diego six runs
allowed in a season low
four and two thirds innings of course
there was that grand slam to machado
but yeah in general yeah change up there
followed into the glove of barnes and
crawford the first out one
two stripling throws a slider that's
lifted to right center field
jeff peterson and cody barrons are going
back and peterson's got it
one on two outs here's kyle seeger kyle
leads the club with his 19 rbis
curveball is in for a base hit and it
clanks off pollock
normally sure handed kyle lewis is
making his way around and he slides
across home
kyle seeger 20 as he gives the mariners
an early one-nothing lead
this is shot up the middle base hit kyle
seeger
coming around third showing off those
wheels he's safe
and it's two nothing mariners leading
things off mookie bets the d-8
this ball is hit to left center field
lopes is back and [ __ ] gets a lead off
home run
even better than advertised if possible
put a k bottom and an s on his chest
because he is superman
that's a good pitch swinging a miss up
in the zone ballinger down on strikes
brings up beatty bases loaded nobody out
dodgers down by run second inning
but threatening here it hit him
and the game is tied on an o2 pitch
a front foot breaking ball literally
tied at two
bottom of the second but the base is
loaded mookie bets
swats the first pitch that he sees into
right for a base hit to give the dodgers
the lead
muncie into score here comes peterson
he is ow
outfit assists for dylan moore with a
tag from austin nola to get peterson
but the dodgers have taken the lead as
bets has driven in his second of the
game
and a fly ball to right field it's well
hit
and corey seeger will cut around the
bases
and say hello to his big brother kyle
three-run shot for corey seeger and a
smile for big bro as he rounds third and
heads home
priceless facial reactions from both
breaking ball
and then he gets all of it and he's
still he's there there was no
frustration
that was total like that was a good
swing
that's awesome moment from the backyard
done the big league field
look for it sit on it if you will
here's a ride deep out to center field
and gone
kyle lewis welcome to dodger stadium
or you can just destroy a fastball here
is kyle seeger
seeger going right back same territory
next pitch ballinger gone back-to-back
smashes
all right seeger versus seeger corey
seeger with a three-run homer now kyle
the older brother says i got your home
run right here
six five ball game
white lifts this deep out to right field
evan white there's another
avid white with one swing gets the
mariners
in front seven to six
here's kyle seeger kyle with a great
night already two for two with a single
and a home run swinging a ground ball to
the right side and it gets on by muncie
sliding to his right
here comes dylan moore in the score from
third lewis running
second heading for third he'll make it
easily and it's now the mariners eight
and the dodgers six
and what a night for big brother kyle
the two brothers are giving
the parents a lot to be excited about we
like the little smirks and the little
comments as they're passing by each
other we're kind of getting a kick out
of that
kyle's like really corey i mean it's
just both of them and then corey just
gave the little nod
like all right you got a one you get you
can't let me one-up you at all
not only does the tying run reach but
betts comes up representing the go-ahead
run
the 1-1
driven out to right dylan moore flags it
down
a fun night for the seeger brothers
ground ball that will get through oh he
smoked it
and got over the glove of crawford 106
off of the bat for seeger and he's
aboard to open the seventh
the bases are loaded nobody out gil to
pollock
swings away at the first pitch and
singles into left
station to station they go it's an 8-7
game on an rbi single from paula
trying run now 90 feet away still nobody
out as muncie comes out
on another payoff pitch muncie tries to
lay off
and does successfully to tie the game
boy took a little bit of a gamble with
that confident back flip before the
check down to third
adrian johnson says no swing and the
game is tied at eight
back at square one locked at eight still
nobody out
base is loaded for peterson bouncing
ball up the middle crawford to the bag
across his body to first a double play
the dodgers take the lead though
nine eight as bellinger steps on home
three in the bank here in the seventh
pollica third two gone and a two-two to
kiki hernandez
lifted to left field in deep lopes his
back on it
that one's gone hernandez comes through
with a two-run home run and they've got
their second
five-run inning tonight
[Applause]
evan white absolutely drills this out to
left
evan white his first career
multi-homer game of the show
and it was a bomb
as the dodgers will begin the inning
with mookie betts
in play seeger 360
the stretch and out number one gold
glove at third base for the mariners
great play by kyle it's up quickly and
just slings it over there
let evan white do the rest of it out
away from his seventh save
this is a heavyweight bout right here
there they go here it comes high
pop fly down the right field line way up
there
peterson the call in the catch and the
dodgers hang on
oh what a wild ride this one was they
went at 11-9
and have won six in a row